ladies and gentlemen of NASA this is  Charles Xavier help is on the way doing  space missions now cool we get the  astronauts we bring them home go heat  signatures rising fast we gotta get out  of here where's Jean  where is she  she should be dad did you hear what the  kids are calling you  Phoenix hello gene who are you the  better question is who are you  something's happening to me you lose  control bad things happen but it feels  good that power destroyed everything  that ever came into contact with until  you the x-men fear you and what they  fear we seek to destroy oculus ooh  a girl dies  she's still offering  she's not Jean anymore  threatening me that's right  [Music]  you